You don't have a ribber, you don't
hand knit, but you want ribbing.
Many machine knitting turn to Mock Ribbing
for the hems and cuffs of their sweaters.
Here are three needle arrangements
that are surprisingly pretty
that will give you the ribbed look.
You want to create these ribs.
You'll be hanging a hem after
knitting with needles out of work.
The hem is doubled and it
looks great on both sides.
And no one will ever know
that this isn't a knit
stitch and purl stitch ribbing.
Many knitters learn a 1x1
mock rib when they get started.
You simply cast on with waist yarn and you
knit some scrap over every other needle
and then just knit one
row with ravel cord.
You'll keep every other needle in out
of work position as you knitting
the length of your ribbing.
So knit twice the desired
length of your ribbing.
Then pick up the loops from the first row
of knitting and place them
on the empty needles.
Knit your garment in pattern and we'll
talk about finishing in a minute.
This is nice, but watch the next one.
You'll be surprised at what a difference
there is with 2x1 mock ribbing.
This is just a simple needle arrangement
change. This time with waist yarn cast on,
leaving every third needle
in out of work position.
Knit a few rows, hang weights if you like,
and then knit one row with ravel cord so
you have two needles in and one
needle out across the work.
This time be sure to pick up all
of the open stitches on the first row
of knitting between the first row
and the ravel cord and hang
them on the needles in work.
Put the empty needles back into working
position so all of your needles are
in working position, and knit your
garment piece according to your pattern.
Pretty nice, isn't it?
Let's take this idea one step further.
Caston and knit scrap over this needle
arrangement, this 3x1.
Three needles in one needle out
of work all the way across.
Knit a row of ravel cord
and then knit your ribbing
for the desired length.
When you pick up this time again,
be sure to pick up all of the open
stitches from that first row of knitting.
You don't want any drop stitches
for all three methods.
Remove the scrap and ravel and you'll see
that the hem is beautiful on both sides.
Insert a ruler or a straight edge
and pull down to set the stitches.
A little bit of steam.
You don't want to iron your ribbing.
Just a little bit of steam and you'll have
a beautiful fast ribbed look without the
fuss of hand knitting or using a ribber.
Thanks for watching.
If you haven't tried Mock ribbing,
take a look at machine knitting
now tutorial on the subject.
Also look for other tutorials on different
types of hems that you can
incorporate in your sweaters.